[Musik]
wer diese reise unternimmt tut dies
meist nicht freiwillig das ziel heißt
oslo prix opel gemeinde sowie
30 km hinter b zuhinterst in einem jura
tal
es ist eine reise an den rand der
gesellschaft
[Musik]
hier leben 100 männer und frauen die
meisten alkohol abhängig andere mit
psychischen problemen oft schwierige
menschen
alle haben schon eine reihe von
therapien hinter sich sind durch
zahlreiche anstalten und kliniken
gegangen
vergebens nun gelten sie als
austherapiert angekommen hier im letzten
netz
[Musik]
phion kommen 57 jahre alt gut behütet
aufgewachsen in biel
er hat die militär angefangen zu trinken
und kam deswegen mit 29 jahren zum
ersten mal in eine klinik
gelegentlich treffen sich die männer zu
einem kaffee bier und oman ist ein
liebenswürdiger mensch wenn er betrunken
ist kann er jedoch ziemlich rabiat
werden
seit 17 jahren lebt er nun an diesem ort
zuerst zwangsweise wie die meisten doch
inzwischen ist es ihm recht hier
[Musik]
herunter
das basteln atelier bietet den bewohnern
niederschwellige tätigkeiten lake bucko
niewisch ein gebürtiger pole ist
alkoholkrank
das ist mir klar ich während meines
lebens aber was ich machen tragen ich
kann das begrenzen und vielleicht auch
unsere reduzieren aber das ist und wo
ist der bruch gekommen der absturz das
ist gekommen dass ich mich mit meiner
frau getrennt habe er das zum von sieben
und acht jahre die salzschicht
viele haben sowie je mittlerweile als
lebensort akzeptiert
lake bucko wird jedoch ist erst vor
wenigen tagen angekommen
unfreiwillig durch eine sogenannte
fürsorgerischer unterbringung und er
möchte so bald wie möglich wieder weg
[Musik]
es ist frühling und 2 sind glücklich sie
haben sich im hospiz von willi gefunden
auch michael michl hat ihn ein unnötiges
leben durch kinderheime kliniken und
strafanstalten führte ist inzwischen zu
einem mehr oder weniger zufriedenen
menschen geworden
das ist der ort wo dieses unersättliche
dringendste verlangen gestellt werden
kann
an stilen vor der tür die sich jeden tag
pünktlich um 13 uhr öffnet zum
flüchtigen glück dieses heim bietet
seinen bewohnern einen kontrollierten
alkoholkonsum individuell abgestimmt auf
krankheit und medikamente man mag das
als kapitulation sehen doch alle hier
haben es schon anders versucht immer
wieder erfolglos
nun ist es wie es ist das sagen bevor
blutlinie ins bodenlose stürzte war er
buchhalter in einer genfer
rohstoffhandels firma
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aus dort mit einem auto festgenommen
die adelsfamilie immobilie wird niemand
mehr gegen seinen willen in einen
anderen besseren menschen verwandelt so
will er gehört zu den wenigen orten oder
das menschliche scheitern eingestanden
wird hier macht man sich nichts mehr vor
es besteht keine notwendigkeit dazu
viele leben jahrzehnte hier fast ein
ganzes leben
einige bleiben ewig jeden mittwoch
bietet das basteln atelier eine
knifflige beschäftigung an die
gewaschenen socken der pensionäre in
einem wilden haufen auf dem tisch
liegend sollen wieder zu machen finden
[Musik]
marketing gold leiteten
gesundheitsdienst seit 38 jahren
arbeitet sie im hospiz sie hat noch jene
zeiten erlebt als renitente bewohner im
keller in käfige gesperrt wurden als
sowie je eine besserungsanstalt war
mittlerweile hat sich viel verändert so
willi ist bei aller tragik ein
menschenfreundlicher ort geworden so
menschenfreundlich halt wie es die
umstände gestatten
peter laub cover 38 jahre lang
unternehmer in kolumbien ist reich
geworden im verlagswesen
es war ein gutes leben teure wagen eine
segeljacht in der karibik doch dann
wurde er von seinen geschäftspartnern
betrogen und bedroht er verlor alles
noch wirksamer als die medikamente war
der alkohol mittellos wurde der
alkoholkranke in die schweiz abgeschoben
wo ihm dem gebürtigen bieler in sowie je
eine neue bleibe zugewiesen wurde
die möglichkeit letzter netz suchen
alternativen nicht funktioniert
da hätten wir doch
[Musik]
was machen
doch nicht das größte auf der 69 jährige
erhält hier limitiert sein bier
er begrüßt dieses konzept und das werden
die sehr gut
[Musik]
el sheikh bogojevic ist organist und die
musik ist seine tägliche flucht da waren
in der vergangenheit einige fehlschläge
beim versuch vom alkohol wegzukommen
doch so willi habe ihm nun die augen
geöffnet sagt ihr spital selbst familien
selbst in 66 hatte ich ja ist das nicht
lebensgefährlich ja so viel ich nicht
habe viele normale nächste gar nicht
klingt das reichste promi status
ich konnte zum beispiel also jetzt
vielleicht nicht weil jetzt habe ich
fast vier wochen nichts getrunken
aber wenn ich in die phase war ich
konnte eine flasche wodka sage ich gar
nicht betrunken
das gibt ihnen einen grund um zu trinken
war der apotheker die suchen sich
einfach einen grund
[Musik]
aber red bull sei
doch karl storndorf dann der gegner
ghana hat bin ich zu dann aber nach 20
jahren kommen nicht ins blaue und die
vikings brauche ich konnte geheime und
ich gar nicht wusste ob er bot mir josi
und so lebt ernst egner nun seit 31
jahren in sowie lee als zufriedener
mensch wie er sagt
david ist im küchendienst tätig der name
ist geändert und auch sonst bleibt der
mann in diesem film unkenntlich
der gut 30 jähriger war kadermann einer
bank ehrgeizig verdiente mehr als ein
bundesrat bis ein burn out und der tod
des vaters ihn aus der bahn warfen dhabi
zehn wurde zum koma trinker mit immer
kürzeren absturz in der ball ja stürzend
eigentlich im sommer musste da sie mir
wirklich bis ins koma trinker also
wirklich wieder eine kurzschlussreaktion
so jetzt in chemie ins koma
und wenn der entschluss gefasst den
geht's zurück mehr
am arm die spuren des lebensbedrohlichen
letzten absturz es hier in einem wald
bei so willi für den hoch intelligenten
mann war es ein leichtes sich dafür
genügend alkohol von außerhalb zu
besorgen was ich mit ursächlich für den
absturz war ich zu meinte lange
einsamkeit
was mir in der institution eigentlich
wirklich fertig person mit meiner
adäquate niveau um eine konversation
kann für ihre und das findelbaby 90
prozent der bewohner
es ist sommer geworden endlich auch hier
auf 850 meter über meer
lorenz hasler jagd nach mäusen früher
habe er mehr bier gesoffen als eine kuh
wasser sagt er
bis seine frau genug hatte wie seine
zwei söhne heute aussehen weiß lorenz
hasler nicht einem betreuer ist das
kunststück gelungen einige bewohner für
eine fußballmannschaft zu gewinnen
diese will in einigen tagen ein kumpel
turnier bestreiten
sport ist nicht gerade der antrieb von
claude reni er das wort der einstige
buchhalter gelangte auf einem indien
trieb auch dank trugen zu einem neuen
bewusstsein
die reise der erkenntnis endete in den
gassen berns worin er als obdachloser
überlebte
seit 20 jahren wirkt er nun in so willi
als philosoph und dichter die bergkette
unübersichtlich es ist ein weg frei
besucher
aber da bin ich zum glück noch lange
nicht beendet die orte werden wie sabine
spitz wolfgang overaths leer gestanden
[Musik]
interessant und musikkonzern sony music
und zu den helden seiner jugend gehört
auch jimi hendrix der es leider nicht
bis sowie schaffte der geniale gitarrist
starb an einer überdosis leben an drogen
und medikamenten bereits im alter von 27
jahren 1970 als der junge claude ring
noch nicht mal buchhalter war
[Musik]
wenn die fahrten pro tag später kotick
ist daher heute aber er behauptet sie
und ebenso abgeändert wurden jeweils
morgens arbeitet gern kommen einige
stunden im textil atelier mit repression
beruhigung und stabilisierung
brause
[Musik]
und dann ist fußball angesagt das
grümpelturnier in sowie die ochsen mit
bio tonnen im tor
[Musik]
und plötzlich ist da eine beweglichkeit
die man längst verloren glaubte doch
alle unbill lässt sich nicht abwenden
[Musik]
gelegentliche schwindelgefühle planen
den torwart unentschieden eins zu eins
damit lässt sich einigermaßen zufrieden
in die pause gehen in die dringend
benötigte rauchpause
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sabine nachts kochen heimleiterin renate
gohmann ist angetan von der sportlichen
darbietung ihrer pensionäre und hilft
mit tipps zur leibesertüchtigung heil
direktor peter gaymann unterstützt von
der seitenlinie aus den kräftezehrenden
kampf seiner leute einige spieler später
steht fest die ochsen erringen unter
zehn mannschaften den sechsten platz
das darf sich sehen lassen denn sport
gehört der bislang nicht zu den stärken
dieser männer
[Musik]
peter löscher der in seinem früheren
leben unternehmer war in kolumbien tut
die tägliche arbeit die ihm blieb und
reinigt die umgebung des hospiz wie
zieht er bilanz liegt er zurück auf ein
gescheitertes leben und hältst du so
aber das ist jetzt ganz so zügig
vorstellen dass das haben jetzt mit
es war so lang dass sie dass sie nicht
outfit es sind die letzten bilder von
peter löscher seine vorahnung erfüllt
sich bereits einige tage später nach
einem sturz stirbt er im spital von sein
team
[Musik]
patricia steiger hat eine lehre als bau
malerin gemacht als lehrerin musste sie
ihre älteren kollegen auf der baustelle
mit bier versorgen und begann selbst zu
trinken
mit 20 ohne schienen schon sehr stark
und wenn sie die erste abi gemacht
mit 20 wir groß probiert die 40 jährige
walliserin leidet unter chronischen
gelenkschmerzen arthrosen trotzdem
arbeitet sie täglich im geschützten
rahmen von sony seit neun jahren
die pensionäre von so willi werden aus
der küche gut und reichlich versorgt und
zu den mahlzeiten werden jeweils auch
die medikamente verabreicht ärztlich
verordnet
abgestimmt auf die individuelle
krankheitsgeschichte und besonders
diffizil auf die menge des bewilligten
alkohols viele psychopharmaka nicht
immer beliebt bei den leuten
[Musik]
gedacht werde jetzt genau
da macht
[Musik]
es ist eine schwierige gratwanderung die
sehr medikamentenabgabe zu wenig davon
würde bedeuten dass fehler der
heimbewohner sich gar nicht mehr in
dieser gemeinschaft bewegen könnten
dass aggressionen überhand nehmen oder
dass depressionen ziel enten und zu viel
davon würde sie zu boden ringen
[Musik]
hier saß vor wenigen wochen david 10
der ausgebrannte banker der zum koma
trinker geworden ist ein betreuer grund
sein zimmer sowie je ist ein letztes
netz doch manchmal reicht auch dieses
david 10 hatte mehrere lebensbedrohliche
abstürze in kuba und in workshops
mögliche führung bringen
und da hätte der arzt roland emmerich
schalter und ihre heimat und auch sehr
einfach gefunden der familie als
institution
david senn ist wieder in einer
psychiatrischen klinik hier erinnert er
sich an diesen letzten absturz von songs
der ihm einen gewaltigen schrecken
eingejagt hat hanni und hat die sache
wie wodka cola beziehungsweise das so
organisieren im dorf in familie und
haben mehr norbert wirklich bis zur
bewusstlosigkeit betrunken und wohnen
deinem nächsten tag am sonntag auf die
intensivstation gebracht bin ja dann ist
schon wieder fall klagt sie es ist
eigentlich ein abschluss ziehen sie
verschreckt sich in trier wenn sie
feststellen dass sie das ihren tod am
xmp den abstieg serie sie im nachhinein
wirklich schockiert wie das event lage
die welt lieber willi an um sich danach
wieder aussicht wie ins leben mit job
und wohnen
johannes funktionierens umfeld wo zu mir
staudt und zum wegwerfen oder sogar zum
sterben bin ich schlichtweg ziehen
das konzept von sowie lewa nichts
förderlizenz und doch hat ihn die
erfahrung dort womöglich einen schritt
weitergebracht mir angst macht und zwar
insofern dass sie dort mit bewohnern so
einfach geistig und kognitiv nehme da
sind es leider nicht laufen
in zwei wochen wird david cent die
klinik verlassen können
er glaubt dass er das schlimmste
überstanden hat ideal wäre die die
denken es um felix leiter für ihre
mitarbeit eventuell familie der nahezu
stabilen zustand diese geschichte von
ganz unten könnte sich tatsächlich zum
guten wenden denn inzwischen hat david
10 im alltag wieder tritt gefasst
ein herbstmorgen im jura tal wo sich der
raureif früher zeigt als unten im
mittelland patricia steigers schulter
schmerzt so stark dass sie in diesen
tagen nur kleine maler arbeiten
ausführen kann
mit ihrer situation hier im hospiz ist
die walliserin einigermaßen zufrieden
besonders wenn sie an ihre früheren
klinikaufenthalte denkt die ganze zeit
die scheiß therapie
ich war doch nichts dafür jetzt georg
ich glaube das haben wir mit patricia
steiger darf jeden nachmittag dabei zwei
große bier trinken
[Gelächter]
früher hat sie ihr bier kontingent noch
durch schmuggel aktionen stark erhöht
hat nächtens rucksack ladungen alkohol
herbeigeschafft doch solche
abenteuerlichen aktionen beste bleiben
[Musik]
patricia steiger hat ihren vater einen
alkoholiker nie gekannt und weil die
mutter eine epilepsie karen war wuchs
sie bei pflegeeltern auf
bereits in der primarschule mussten
medikamente dem mädchen das leben
erträglicher machen
[Musik]
die deutsche landschaftsgärtnerin monika
gerlach leitet die
landwirtschaftsbetriebe
die arbeit ist freiwillig doch für alle
tätigkeiten im hospiz heißt hier auf dem
feld die bastel atelier in schreinerei
köche oder sonstwo erhalten die
pensionäre zwei franken stundenlohn
taschengeld das meist für zigaretten
oder alkohol verwendung findet monika
dlr ist froh um jede hand die mit
anpackt mit ihm weil die kisten sind
verdammt schwer
sie kann ich also gar nicht alleine
tragen
und das klappt super sehen wir uns
wieder hier nach der pause findest du
mich
krieg ist einfach in ruhe den biologen
sehen uns ja das gut danke
heute nachmittag arbeitet auch heim
direktor peter croll mann auf dem feld
die futterrüben sollen noch trocken in
die scheune gelangen
denn für den abend ist sturm angesagt
[Musik]
im nebel verborgen der strahl letzten
acht sturmböen von 176 stundenkilometern
wüteten organist scheck bogojevic gibt
gelegentlich in der kirche von will red
er ist nun seit einem halben jahr im
hospiz hat ganz aufgehört mit dem
trinken
es waren sechs monate der schmerzhaften
erkenntnis
[Musik]
man ist schon drin aber man behauptet
nein ich bin noch nicht sicher die
anwender trinken wäre ich nur richtig
ich brauche das zum beispiel drei jahren
bis ich mir gesagt habe ja ich habe sich
durch alkoholprobleme
aber eben das ist das schlimmste was man
weiß nie wann man die grenze gibt schon
überschritten hat schon lange man das
noch nicht wie haben sie festgestellt
dass sie diese grenze überschritten
haben
aber nach meinem aber erst dritten fall
halt ins spital
dann haben wir etwas tatsächlich nicht
aber das muss zuerst etwas passieren
man muss wirklich hier also ich zum
beispiel mit sechs premieren spieltagen
weiter zwei wochen konnte ich glaube die
gehen ja ja dann das realisiert man dass
endlich
[Musik]
leszek bokoni vips bestreben ist es so
will er so bald wie möglich verlassen zu
können
und dieser wille ist heute noch stärker
als vor allem halben jahr
je länger man hier ist desto mehr man
wird sich abgewöhnen vom normalen leben
und das ist daher sehr schwer wieder
zurückzukommen und ich will hier nicht
bleiben
[Applaus]
das geknüpfte paradies unter den fingern
von firmen es soll ein
weihnachtsgeschenk werden sauerkraut und
[Gelächter]
wir würden sie behörden beschreiben
freundlich lieben zu dick ist breit
fleißig anna busch lebt erst seit kurzem
in familie und sie fühlt sich wohl hier
das essen die leute sind alle nett zu
werden und ich habe die ganze welt
gesehen
ich war dreimal in rio de janeiro in new
york im andere jahren in australien
sydney wo hat sie ihn am besten gefallen
in rio de janeiro warum gegen schwimmen
copacabana was super
[Musik]
das amt im land
welchen anzug die person beschäftigt
[Musik]
da ich doch ne woche
fahrt zum einkaufen ins nahe seit ihm
diese möglichkeit steht einen
pensionären offen sofern sie sich an die
hausregeln halten die fahrt dient auch
dazu auswärts alkohol zu konsumieren und
da wird natürlich immer wieder versucht
verbotenerweise alkohol zurück ins heim
zu schmuggeln
auch patricia steigert die bau malerin
ist bei ihrer einkaufstour in erster
linie an bier interessiert meist kann
die walliserin ihren konsum ja gut
dosieren
doch der letzte absturz liegt nur einige
wochen zurück
die 40-jährige kann nicht anders
und sie will auch nicht anders immerhin
mit ihren abstürzen bringt sie niemanden
sonst in bedrängnis und trotz
chronischer gelenkschmerzen leistet sie
ihre tägliche arbeit und bei patricia
steiger abgesehen von den gelegentlichen
abstürzen im hospiz betrieb keine
probleme bereitet darf sie vom einkauf
eine gewisse menge bier zurück in ihr
zimmer mitnehmen entgegen der
hausordnung
mir scheint die nächste pragmatismus
falschen richtig zu sagen ich kenne
zeitig jungs lieber aber wenn sie eine
ganze wird das hospiz von sohn willi ist
das lebenswerk von peter und renate
gollan in den 26 jahren ihres wirkens
hat das direktoren paar dieses
ungewöhnliche heim konzept mit alkohol
abgabe entwickelt gegen viel anfängliche
skepsis so viel freiheit wie möglich so
viele regeln wie unbedingt nötig so
könnte man die heim realität beschreiben
und bietet das kino müssen wir einfach
muss handeln und zwar sehr mühsam mit
ihrem verhalten aber missionen
ich muss es aber gerne und so erfolg mit
viel so willi bietet der gesellschaft
eine kostengünstige lösung ihrer
probleme
die alternative eine klinik etwa wäre
ein mehrfaches teurer
in diesem dörflein unfreiwilliger
bewohner was sammelt sich viel
konfliktpotenzial
und doch scheint es irgendwie zu
funktionieren
[Musik]
stimmlich intern im rahmen sehr gut
funktioniert news corp und dort sonst
nach rumänien um eine starke absturz das
selbst irgendwie das hat die menschen
kennen vielleicht ihren unterstützen die
dame einfach buchen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
an weihnachten erhalten die pensionäre
zum festessen ausnahmsweise zwei
gläschen rotwein offeriert
etwas zwiespältig muten die gefeierten
jubiläen an zehn 20 oder gar 30 jahre im
hospiz doch offenbar schätzen die
jubilare diese ehrung durch die
direktion auch co-trainer für 20 jahre
sowie die einen gutschein in empfang
nehmen
jeder bewohner erhält ein geschenk im
wert von 50 franken
für einige bleibt dass die einzige
weihnächtliche aufmerksamkeit
die angehörigen sind weit weg und oft
auch gar nicht mehr interessiert an
einem engen kontakt zu ihrer entgleisten
tochter oder schwester zu ihrem
gefallenen vater oder sohn
[Musik]
der schnee hat sich an die schattigen
waldränder zurückgezogen
der frühling ist auch zuhinterst im jura
tal angekommen
in der gärtnerei wird der letzte winter
salat gerichtet und auch die
fußballmannschaft hat den winter
überstanden übt schon für das nächste
grümpelturnier
[Musik]
organist jackpot hat es bald geschafft
in einigen wochen wird er so willi
verlassen können
er ist weg vom alkohol aber nicht weg
von der sucht und lake bucko nitsch ist
überzeugt davon dass er fortan das
richtige tun wird im hospiz
verabschiedet er sich mit einer
ausstellung seiner bilder die in einem
jahr so willi entstanden sind gemalte
traumwelten
ich möchte mich ganz herzlich
gratulieren
[Applaus]
ob schon hier keine therapie erhältlich
ist hat so willi bei leszek puniet
therapeutisch gewirkt ich brauchte das
jetzt nicht mehr aber am anfang das war
so das ist zustand ins spital und wenn
ich nicht hier kommen wahrscheinlich
weiter sinken
ja und das ich weiß nicht ob ich noch
ein erstes laues frühlingslüftchen
erlaubt draußen vor der bei zu sitzen
und ein wenig zu träumen
[Applaus]
und claude reni der das glück überall
auf der welt schon suchte wo würde er
gerne leben wenn er nochmals wählen
könnte die liebe hat er immer noch nicht
gefunden
der einstige buchhalter doch verwegene
träume sind ihm geblieben
auch nach 20 jahren im hospiz von so
willi
[Musik]